[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors avant de remettre ce prix j'ai
évidemment une pensée pour tous les
réalisateurs dont le premier film devait
sortir cette année où est sorti dans des
conditions dont il est inutile de
rappeler ici l'extrême dureté pour que
le cinéma français conserve à sa
diversité sa pluralité de regards sa
richesse sa jeunesse enfin tout ce qui
le rend absolument unique
c'est de vous dont on a besoin et
maintenant à vous chers nommé
félicitations à tous vous avez fait des
films magnifiques que vous ne m'avez pas
proposer cet original c'est pas grave je
respecte ne me proposait pas le deuxième
non plus parce qu'il sera moins bon ça
c'est pas un jugement c'est une
statistique
en revanche pour le troisième celui du
du retour en grâce
bonnier plus peur voilà je suis là et
hâte de vous retrouver sur les plateaux